von Laura kenne ich den Satz ich habe
immer an den Frieden geglaubt und im
Moment kämpfe ich darum noch an den
Frieden zu glauben wie ist das
gemeint nun wissen
sie das schlimmere als die der Hass ist
die Angst wenn man Angst hat vor anderen
Menschen ich habe keine Angst vor ihm er
hat keine Angst vor
mir
danke wenn man in den Frieden glauben
möchte
das ist wichtig welche andere Option hat
man ich keine keine andere Option man
muss einfach an den Frieden glauben
glauben sie noch dar ich glaube es ist
ein langer Prozess und dieser Prozess
beinhaltet dass wir uns alle einander
zuhören und versuchen unsere Geschichten
zu verstehen also ich als Palästinenser
jetzt bin Flüchtling in dritter
Generation meine Großeltern wurden 1948
vertrieben der Bruder meiner Großmutter
wurde vor den Augen der Familie ermordet
ne das ist meine Familien